well let's get more now on those local
elections next week joining us now is
Sky's election analyst the associate
member of Nuffield College Oxford
professor Michael fashio thank you for
being with us and you've been doing
every election with Sky since we started
that's my 1980 okay so if you were the
person to talk to you to get the
analysis of what is likely to happen
what should we be looking out for next
week well there are a lot of seats at
stake in these elections and most of the
seats were 40 in 2015 as the
Conservatives won both the general
election and the local elections so
they're defending the most seats so they
have most to lose but so it will be
interesting to focus on concerted losses
but equally it will be interesting to
see which party which of the rival
parties labor all the Liberal Democrats
for example gain the most seats so
there's a lot of interest in what
happened we could have a look now
actually at the current state of the
party because what you're saying is
quite important isn't it and if you have
a look at their some of the
Conservatives I've got more than double
the number of things that they're
defending its the scale of these
elections or most eight and a half
thousand seats in England and of course
there are low collections in Northern
Ireland too so there's a lot of places
with elections and therefore lots of
seats and therefore a great deal of
scope for parties to do badly or parties
to do well and so the Conservatives are
really defending a high position not
only in terms of councillors but also in
terms of the councils that they control
so there's a lot at stake for them so
it's about how many think they lose
really yes because the the baseline is
2015 and since then you'd expect that
where we are in the in the parliament
that the Conservatives would would lose
ground from there the question is really
how much ground they've lost given the
context of where we are okay we've got a
couple of projections haven't we which
show some of the different scenarios we
can have a look now at this is something
that you prepared isn't it for the
Sunday Times yes so what we do is we
each week there are local council
by-elections and you can use those
council violations to see which way the
electoral wind is blowing if you
and based on the projection from from
those results the conservatives and
labour are more or less neck-and-neck
but the liberal Democrats are doing
quite well in local council so we could
see a Lib Dem fight back you could see
it from the long-promised exactly so
therefore the conservative losses are
there or around about 400 but
disproportionately it's the Liberal
Democrats that are picking up seats from
Labour that's the evidence from local
council by-elections and to be honest
though that evidence is beginning to dry
up as these elections these May
elections got closer and closer because
it's interesting isn't it if you look at
the polls things could actually be a lot
worse the Conservatives we can just have
a look here this is the projection if
you look at the polling data yes and it
said it is unusual for pollsters to ask
a question specifically about how will
you vote in local elections but opinion
did that so it's a valuable piece of
information that we have but if you can
look at it compare the Conservatives are
much lower on the opinion poll than they
were in the council by-election
projection laborous is more or less the
same but the Liberal Democrats were also
much lower and therefore in terms of
swing since 2015 the projection from
that is over a thousand seat losses for
the concern seems like an enormous
number it is well it's about one in five
of those that they're defending and I
would say that this is the upper end if
if they really do exceed that number as
they did in 1995 when the Tony Blair's
New Labour's simply wiped them out in
this part of the electoral cycle then
that really will be disaster and how
much do you think we can read into the
local elections results when it comes to
what could happen in a general election
because of course lots of people are
saying that we might have a general
election sooner than we think it's more
difficult than the normal for the simple
reason that is that these local
elections are are being fought for
example we don't have the brexit party
standing any candidates at all
you keep his standing candidates but
many many fewer than they stood in 2017
so therefore you've got all the people
in 15 so you've got all the people that
voted for you Kip into
thousand fifty not having a candidate to
vote for in many places so that
complicates matters also change UK isn't
filled in any local election candidate
so it's more difficult than normal to
project from from the local elections
what's going to happen in a general
election and therefore we really need to
concentrate upon how many seats each
party is losing where the parties that
are advancing or advancing for example
where is labored doing well labour needs
to do well in southern England and I see
that Jeremy Corbyn is visiting
stoke-on-trent a place where labour
traditionally had power there and if
that really is the limit of their
expectations that's that's really set in
the barbary very low indeed so all our
attention will be upon where they've
lost seats and where perhaps they've
picked up councilors what are their key
places that you're going to be looking
out that could give us the best picture
of where the country is currently out
well we look at places like for example
swing where the Conservatives have a
very narrow majority and they only need
to lose one seat to lose narrow control
and in places like that and of course
we've had the context of brexit there
we've had the problems with the Honda
car factory and so it will be
interesting in those kinds of areas to
to see how local issues as your previous
guest was talking about how local issues
will play out against the broader
context of how people voted in the EU
referendum so we'll be looking closely
at the pattern of voting in leave and
most of these local authorities that
have got elections voted leave and in
the referendum so be interesting to see
what happens in those area and of course
if you are and leave voter a noise that
we haven't left the EU already who you
can evoke for if you won't get the two
main parties are kicking yes and that's
why is such an interest instead of
elections because in a sense if you're
angry about not leaving why would you
vote for the Liberal Democrats who
definitely want to stay so it unless
people say I don't care about what the
Liberal government
and say about the EU I'm going to use my
vote in a protest foot and I'm gonna
vote for the Liberal Democrats in local
elections have also gotten a lot of
independence standing as well so it
might be that those independents might
benefit but it's going to be fascinating
in how that you kept vote breaks out in
terms of does it go to the labor does it
go to conservatives does it even go to
the Liberal Democrats fascinating stuff
well we're going to be doing the local
election program there to get that
overnight midnight until 6 a.m. so we're
sure we'll be having a lot more of these
conversations then look forward to it
and thank you very much